maintenant mais dans le même temps voici
que la perspective d'une sortie de
l'euro gagne du terrain le débat n'est
plus taboue regarder chez nous ces
chiffres 35% des français se prononcent
pour l'abandon de la monnaie unique et
le retour au franc un chiffre stable et
même en légère baisse mais ailleurs
l'idée fait son chemin enquête romain
mais si nathalie gallet
et billets d'anciens francs dans la main
nicolas dupont aignan est déjà un
candidat en campagne présidentielle la
proposition n'a pas changé sortir de
l'euro cette monnaie unique qui seraient
responsables de tous les maux retrouver
notre liberté monétaire c'est faire le
jeu de l'emploi du pouvoir d'achat des
exportations de la relocalisation nos
activités si nous faisons cette campagne
c'est parce que l'euro est un poison une
croisade anti euro qui ne rassemble pas
encore les foules mais qui depuis le
début de la crise a convaincu de jeunes
militants à mon avis d'actualité nous
donne raison et je pense que ce qu'on
défend nous on pourra pas nous taxer
d'opportunisme ça fait longtemps qu'on
le défende nicolas dupont aignan entend
conduire sa caravane un peu partout en
france dans les prochains mois
l'assemblée nationale n'était qu'une
étape
à berlin aussi s'opposer à l'euro n'est
plus un tabou il y a même ceux qui ont
retourné leur veste cet ancien leader du
patronat allemand a autrefois soutenu
l'euro dans ce livre sauver notre argent
il demande aujourd'hui une séparation de
l'europe en deux zones avec deux
monnaies différents alzonne en soit il
ne faut pas croire les dirigeants
politiques qui disent que la séparation
de la zone euro mettent en péril
l'avenir de l'europe en europe c'est
absurde car ce save the world sans
l'euro nous étions déjà amis et nous
avions de bonnes relations économiques
et culturelles c'est bien la preuve
qu'il faut réformer cette monnaie
les dirigeants européens ont pris
conscience de cette fronde et tente
semaine après semaine de garde et
l'adhésion de l'opinion
si l'euro échoue alors l'europe échoué
il faut prendre cela très au sérieux
un message pas toujours entendus dans
les pays en difficultés financières
comme la grèce
athènes dans les manifestations cette
année le drapeau européen a brûlé plus
souvent il n'a flotté